the guys upon stars have seen and bought
at all and though they love wheeling and
dealing they don't love telling people
that their treasured family heirlooms
are worthless from pistols to diamonds
these are fake items that devastated
their owners on Pawn Stars a seller
strolls in believing he has something
really special in his possession a 50
million-year-old piece of Baltic amber
with a fossilized tarantula trapped
inside he presents it to Chumlee in the
hopes of getting $50,000 for it turns
out he's in luck as there's a gemstone
expert already at the pawn shop I
actually have a gemstone expert here all
right hold on yeah the seller has
authentication papers from an
entomologist but the expert doesn't
think that's the correct person to
authenticate a gemstone so he suggests
sending it off to the Gemological
Institute of America the organization
that sets the quality standards for
diamonds and other stones a catch is it
cost a lot to do that it cost about $200
to send it away well that sounds good
I'll do that
well when the results come back it's a
huge disappointment the gemstone is
really nothing more than a hunk of
plastic the disillusioned seller is
clearly disappointed the sax John Lennon
was a well-known doodler who attended
art school before founding the legendary
Beatles and he often gave away his
drawings for free so it's not
far-fetched to believe a seller may have
walked into the Gold & Silver Pawn Shop
with a collage of doodles that resembled
Lennon's most famous artwork a
haphazardly hand-drawn self-portrait and
it's signed the seller found it hanging
in a thrift shop and bought it for $10 a
total steal now he's hoping it's worth
$20,000 at the pawn shop while Rick
calls the fine needs he immediately
spots a problem with the alleged
artifact from the back he can tell it's
been printed on Kodak printer paper
which didn't exist at the time of
Lennon's tragic death in 1980
unfortunately for the owner it's a
complete fake trying to stay optimistic
about the bus the seller says he's glad
he didn't pay a lot for it in the first
place Marchand linen is actually a John
lemon a kaki seller wants 1 million
dollars for a one in a million photo of
President Abraham Lincoln and his wife
Mary from 1863 that would be right in
the middle of Lincoln's historic
administration which ran from 1861 to
1865 but Rick isn't sure it's real so he
calls in an expert to use his software
to compare the sellers photo with an
authenticated photo may
facial features do not match among other
things so she declares it a fake the
seller doesn't take the news well
belligerently saying he considers
himself more of an expert on the subject
than the actual expert when she defends
her record of spotting fakes and sticks
to her guns that the photo is an
authentic the seller declares is your
career you have a right to this credit
yourself after watching the exchange in
disbelief Rick takes the word of the
renowned expert over the sulky seller
and refuses to make an offer flintlock
pistols were common in colonial America
so when a gun collector walks into the
pawn stars pawn shop with a pristine one
allegedly from the Revolutionary War
big Hoss is interested in buying it the
seller purchased it for $800 at a gun
show and he calls it the cream of his
collection he's only getting rid of it
in the first place because his wife is
forcing him to sell it before handing
over any money big Hoss calls an arms
and armor expert to come check it out
there's no authentication paperwork but
if it's legit the expert says it could
be worth up to $2,500 but as soon as the
expert looks at the pistol he says it's
a reproduction as it's missing certain
markings and isn't hand engraved big
Hoss feels bad for the guy but that
doesn't mean he's willing to make an
offer
outside the seller unload storming off
while swearing yes okay maybe the thing
is is is a fake of the legendary Babe
Ruth's is one of the best known sports
stars of all time so memorabilia signed
by him should fetch a pretty penny
that's what one no-nonsense seller
believes when he walks through the
pawnshop doors with a signed baseball
bat glove between the two items he's
hoping to get a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars when Rick says he wants
to bring in an expert the seller
bristles and asked who the man is Rick
calmly explains he knows and trusts the
experts while he doesn't know the seller
from a hole in the wall right off the
bat the sellers authentication paper
makes the expert nervous because the
person who signed the papers was
implicated in an FBI sting exposing
fraudulent signatures on memorabilia
therefore auction houses won't accept
the signature as legitimate
Rick understandably has serious doubts
about the validity of the items which
immediately shuts down the deal after
leaving the shop without a sale the
frustrated seller questions the expert I
think they're missing the boat on these
items this young guy
not even sure he heard of paper one
authentic 1967 Pete Rose baseball card
in mint condition could be worth about
$1,500 and only about 75 are known to
exist having five of them would be a
pretty big windfall for the right seller
that's why big Hoss is suspicious when a
guy comes in with just that five mint
condition 1967 tops cards that are just
too perfect the seller says he'll have
to reevaluate his entire collection if
these turn out to be fake big Hoss calls
over Rick and it takes in no time to
tell him they're duds so what you want
to know about this is the real know Rick
explains the color is faded and blurry
they also looked like they were printed
on an inkjet printer once outside the
apparently disillusioned seller
questions his whole existence leading to
this all-time great Pawn Stars moment
because these cards are faked and you
know what else is real the wife real the
dog the cat you know what's real guess
he's going to go home and take a second
look at his card collection among other
things
Amelia weep occults bronze Perseus and
Pegasus sculpture from 1888 was a
limited-edition of 800 and it's the
artists most famous work so when a
seller comes in asking only $6,000 for
one Rick's eyes light up Rick knows
there are millions of fakes in the art
world so he inspects it first and
immediately finds a made in the USA
stamp on the bottom
it's obviously a 20th century recast man
after pre-call died in 1915 after
receiving the news the seller goes
ballistic accusing Ric of incompetence
like his fee no which you can please
through the front of it I don't care
what you're saying I don't care what you
tell me but I know you're full of things
get heated enough that security comes
over but Rick waves them off Rick's
father Pawn Stars legendary old man
steps in to cool things off calmly
thinking the man for bringing in the
item but saying they're not interested
with sculpture in hand and security
keeping an eye on him the seller knows
there isn't going to be any deal so he
storms out Stradivarius violins are a
rare commodity as their maker Antonio
Stradivari only produced just under a
thousand his lifetime he handmade them
from the late 1600s until his death in
1737 as a result most of his instruments
are pushing 300 years old
therefore they're worth big money to
anyone in the market for one no matter
its condition that's why Chumlee gets
when a man walks in with one he says was
passed down from his grandfather it's in
rough shape though the instrument is
cracked and peeling and even looks like
someone tried to glue a piece back
together if real it would definitely be
worth a lot of money but Chumlee doesn't
think it's worth what the seller is
asking so of course he brings in a
Stradivarius expert the expert explains
that it's the craftsmanship and
attention to detail that sets
Stradivarius instruments apart and just
by looking at the varnish he can tell
that this violin is a reproduced homage
from the 1830s to the 1960s these
knockoffs were mass-produced by the
millions making this item basically
worthless but unlike similar stories
that ended in rage over the dashed
dreams of extra zeros and the sellers
bank accounts this one ends on a sweet
notes with the owner saying he plans to
hang it on his wall in honor of his
grandfather Marilyn Monroe is one of the
most glamorous and iconic movie stars
ever and her dramatic death only adds to
her mystique so it's not surprising that
our autograph and anything related to
her would be highly coveted cue a seller
who walks into the pawn stars shop with
a signed photo and a handwritten poem by
the blonde beauty
he says he's had four experts
authenticated and the two items are
appraised at a total of $48,000 still
big Hoss wants his own expert to weigh
in unfortunately they're both poor
juries the expert says it's widely known
that Marilyn's secretary used to sign
autographs for her with a red pen and
wouldn't you know it this signature is
in red ink as for the poem the
handwriting doesn't look anything like
the Stars real handwriting the poem also
was not penned by Miss Monroe which
causes disappointment all around well I
wish you were real man I mean we both
make a lot of money a painting by Swann
Miro once pitched 37 million dollars at
auction so when someone walks in with
another piece by Miro Chumlee gets
excited the artist happens to be one of
chums favorites which makes him more
knowledgeable than usual well the seller
would like to get $12,000 for it Chumlee
thinks the signature looks questionable
it's lacking fluidity as if someone had
forged it Chum wants to call in an
expert and he says he's one of the most
faked artists around the experts
presence makes the seller nervous
because he's not sure the etching is
genuine upon inspection it looks like an
original print and for a brief moment
the seller is be me but the signature
seems like a forgery the experts final
opinion it's a real Miro etching with a
fake signature and he tells Chumlee to
avoid purchasing it
the seller says he'll probably just keep
it and hang it on his wall jewelry
always sells well at the pawn stars shop
so Rick is intrigued when a young man
comes in with a 300 year old 15 karat
gold and rose diamond cross he's looking
to get $8,000 for it
Rick immediately recognizes it as
Baroque style which was popular in the
17th and 18th centuries and says jewelry
from that time period can sell for
millions of dollars he carefully
inspects the piece with a magnifying
glass and sees no hallmarks of it being
genuine
including the gold being two different
colors in fact it looks like someone
soldered it together and blowtorches
didn't exist in the 1600s it's clearly
not 300 years old to add insult to
injury there's probably only $200 worth
of actual gold to be had and the
diamonds aren't even worth Rick's time
the seller disagrees with Rick's
appraisal and says he's going to get a
second opinion the 1912 sinking of the
RMS Titanic in the North Atlantic Ocean
is one of the most well known events in
history so when a seller struts into the
pawn shop with a mint condition Boston
Globe newspaper from the day after the
Titanic sank he thinks he's going to
make Bank while looking at the
sensational headline Titanic sinks 1500
die Ricci immediately notes the paper is
in almost to perfect condition
as he flips through the pages there's no
yellowing which is extremely rare for a
100 year old paper Rick quickly declares
it's a fake saying it looks like it came
from a copy machine when the surprise
seller asked when someone might have
made the copy big Hoss quips early right
after the movie came out well the guy is
disappointed he admits that once Rick
opened the paper up and pointed out the
excellent condition me knew it was fake
to check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite stuff are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]